well what i can see uh is uh
about maybe one year worth of work
uh that started pretty much when the
pandemic started
um and then i guess was influenced by
you know i mean some of the paintings
actually deal with uh
death but in a positive way because in
our culture
we think that death is something not to
be spoken about in many other culture
it's just a step you know or it's just
part of life so we have that
a lot of the paintings were influenced
by me spending more time
in nevala desert because
you know a lot of work was done remotely
at that point
and we had a little more free time and
to be
to stay grounded and to avoid people
i mean obviously nature here is
wonderful
and i guess i got inspired by it's just
absolutely stunningly beautiful um
it grows on you i'm not gonna lie and
say
you know i'm from france paris
originally but i've been in america for
many years
for my career but i was mostly north
you know north of the country so
everything is green
and so when i came here it was a shock
but then when you spend time within it
you know with all the textures and the
rocks and the colors the wind the smell
i obviously wasn't inspired about it and
you can see that
people that collect my work and know my
work
will see not a difference but we'll see
something else
happening and mostly the structure the
the texture
i use i use different textures you know
i do my own little like a cook
my little secrets you know i do my own
little cuisine
using paint and i created very
interesting i think textures in my
workout
might be new for people that i used to
collect my
art or my prints or whatnot so i was
four years in kentucky and then before
prior to that i was
i think about 16 years at least
in cincinnati where i was teaching
teaching graphic design
and that's where really my art career
started i was commissioned to do many
many paintings for
several groups and several people
influential people that i will name
here but you know that own 20 cars and
fly
planes so they're not hurting for money
and
that obviously helped me during my
career to you know
stay an artist and and and make a living
at it
i'm teaching my wonderful students i say
hi to my students
i love you guys um yeah i'm teaching uh
drawing and coloring drawing as well
using pastel
all kinds of mixed media i use a lot of
mixed media in my art itself so
it's a vague interesting fun and
creative experience for
my students and they usually tell me
that it's a
brush of fresh air a breath of fresh air
for them in in academia to be able to
learn and have fun and and touch things
and make things with their hands
and create art it's something especially
in during those times of
hardship and isolation it's something
that they really enjoy
life i mean what you're going through
but mostly mostly what we are all going
through
i'm not i'm not about divine division
i'm not about
pointing at things that might divide
people
i'm not political that way you know i'm
not trying to make a statement
but if i am and i think what i say i'm
not trying as
i am trying i'm trying to bring people
together and i'm not a politician so
it's not an empty promise
you know you hear all politicians saying
well i can bring people together and
they never do
because that's the game of politics i'm
not into politics
but i really want to talk about we all
whatever we all go through so we know
isolation was one of them togethernet
togetherness there's a lot of paintings
on on speech
it's free speech it's one of them it's a
hot topic
but also free speech mean being
responsible
with your words and so some of my
paintings talk about
being responsible with your words when
you watch your words a lot of
you'll see a lot of eyes being linked
with line to the mouth
which literally means in my art keeping
an eye on what you say
so it's not about being pc it's about
being mindful
you know and i think you know we can all
improve the way we relate to each other
without falling into those caricatures
that the press
at large tends to do you know wow the pc
culture
all that stuff i think we can all
benefit from
being respectful to one another and
you know being mindful about your
project what you say
absolutely you know i grew up my whole
family is a family of artists
my great grandfather was the
impressionist the way we're now really
well known
he would be turning his grave if we
if he knew that yeah he died in 1903.
so uh but kami pisaro was if you can
google it you know coming visceral
was the the father considers the
father's depressionist so he started
the movement of taking the easel
from the studio outside in nature and so
it created the impressionists he taught
many artists at the time
so he had several sons
all were also artists maybe not as well
known
my father which hi dad is going to turn
100 years old this summer in july
he's also an artist and a graphic
designer and you know
i am also an artist in the graphic
design as a little child
my father didn't take me to the ball
game my father took me to museum
and it was about it was a dread because
i wanted to play with the kids
i want to play soccer he said oh we got
to go to the art museum so i was going
to the optimism
so i was so tired of it that
i would run in the museum and whatever
whatever piece would that stop me was
the one that i would spend looking at
and i realized that
what i'm looking for in art is something
that stops me first that grabs me
doesn't impact and then when you stop
you know which we meaning you pay
attention
then the painting has to have all kind
of little secret and within it
in the way it's done the way it's built
to keep you interested
and to keep you guessing so what the way
i think
i'm trying to do that i'm trying to make
you stop
and wonder how it was done how was this
texture made
how is this line is that painted what
kind of paint is that
i think that's i've seen so many
paintings that i'm trying to do
paintings that don't really look like
paintings
because i've seen too many so i'm trying
to have fun with my process
and i want people in the viewer that
look at the paintings wondering how it's
done it's made a little bit like a magic
trick
if they feel something that's wonderful
uh
that would be number one number two i
want them to feel
um most of the paintings are very
positive i
i i'm a positive person and
i'm a reflective person you know attend
i think artists should not be in the
crowd they should be
on the side of the crowd sorry and then
look at stuff and try to figure it out
but you know i'm positive i believe in
positive images so if you look at my
work first of all most of them
all of them say are really happy in
colors brightening colors
so the mood is is you know happy and
strong
and then when you get into each painting
you'll see there are a little star is
within
so and everybody i know while i'm
creating that line
where i'm creating that dot what it
means to me but
i want people to just kind of figure out
on their own
you know like a lot of things
if i look at this line you know when i
saw
when i do several eyes i don't do that
all of them
it means that you're gonna have
different point of views
that's what i want to express you know
there is none
there's not only one way to look at
things and that's why we're being sold
we're being sold a very black and white
word where it's either wrong
and right or right and there is nothing
in between
life by experience is a lot of gray
zones it's a lot of
you know we have to be more uh
understanding of people's situations and
people's life
less judgmental and that's the way for
me to express that
of course most people wouldn't know it
and then eventually
it becomes it becomes an interesting
uh way of expressing and creating on
you know so the way i work i work with
thoughts
words sentences that become lines
dots colors and they all fit within each
other
it is sometimes a word would come to my
mind which leads to a painting
like this one for instance sometimes an
image comes to my mind
and the word comes afterwards so it's a
it's an interesting process
a lot of it is just
the way i work i don't plan too much
ahead
because i don't want to know what i'm
doing so much i want to be entertained
i want to be surprised i want to have
fun in the process
so if i'm doing something uh you know
so tight then then the only task i have
is to blow it up
there's no fun in it for me anyways so i
like to have
you know a general idea and then let it
happen
so in order to have 20 paintings that
i'm proud
and happy with to show i might have to
do 40.
you know that's the way i work it's my
first show in las vegas i'm very happy
very i mean so far
i mean i got a lot of written a lot of
people saying that they'll come they're
happy to
see that happening and it's very
supportive and i'm very excited
and and appreciate all followers i mean
with this team they did a great job
hanging the show it's wonderful
it feels good uh it's a it's like when
uh people might know no
know that but as an artist is like an
actor you know you're in the movie
my older son is an actor in france and
he tells me that all the time
you know you get a part for a movie and
then you don't really know what they're
going to do
with your part until you see the cut and
sometimes you're happy about it
and sometimes you're not and you have
very little control you know you did
your job and that's it
this is something for a painter you know
i did the paintings i deliver the
painting
then i don't know how it's going to work
out and i'm pleased to see that they
didn't want a phone job that it's
just brilliant well since since i'm i'm
new in las vegas i mean
fairly new in las vegas if we take out
the
carving 19 because we had to the show
was scheduled
and we had to push it back twice already
and waiting for better time and i think
uh we all agree that better times are
here uh
i can say already that more people are
coming back to las vegas
but for people that know me i don't see
why you know
necessarily they should know me since
i'm new in las vegas just google my name
it's simple search you'll see what i've
done i've got a weekly page i've got all
kinds of stuff there
and you'll be more informed about you
know what i've done and
so far and and maybe you know want to
show up and
see us on friday